more than 26 million people along the
eastern seaboard are under a flash flood
watch this morning heavy downpours
triggered massive flooding in central
Pennsylvania yesterday floodwaters
swamped roads and homes and swept away
cars at least one person who fell into a
swollen creek is missing look at those
pictures the dangerous storm system is
stalled over the East Coast the National
Weather Service warns it could create
more life-threatening situations heavy
downpours are expected to last most of
the week tonita copal is in Hummelstown
Pennsylvania Tony good morning good
morning here come the rains again if you
want a preview of what could be in store
for much of the East Coast this is it
I'm standing in Swatara Creek typically
a place where people can wade across
instead it's now a raging river and out
there in the middle where there is
normally about 10 feet of clearance
you've got debris stacking up against
the bridge including right there in the
middle a dumpster threatening the bridge
itself now that missing person a young
woman she disappeared along a different
flooded Creek about 30 minutes from here
where get this they got a month of rain
in mere days rescuers searched in the
dark for a woman swept away in a swollen
creek near Harrisburg last night the 19
year old was walking with a friend when
they both went under the friend was able
to escape safely about 80 miles
northwest of Philadelphia raging
floodwaters swallowed the town of
tramonto in Sylvania officials there
declared a disaster emergency because of
the flash flooding help save me a nearby
Pine Grove a stranded driver took cell
phone video of the flooding as he sat on
top of his car rescue crews eventually
pulled him from the water
three days of rain across central
Pennsylvania has saturated the ground
giving water few places to go
fire crews spent the day rescuing many
people from vehicles that didn't make it
through the flooded roads those
abandoned vehicles and clogged streets
hampering other rescue efforts it makes
it tougher to get everybody around and
stuff for that emergency personnel
looking out of the work in Hershey
Pennsylvania the famous Hershey Park and
neighboring Zoo America closed because
of flooding drone shots show the extent
of the rising waters the park is
scheduled to reopen today and here at
Hummelstown the water is still rising
and rising by the minute I can feel
myself having to inch out further onto
dry land the National Weather Service is
advising people if you come across
something like this and that's highly
likely in the days ahead turn around
there's a useful useful reminder turn
around don't drown
John no need Thanks it's very good
advice turn around don't drown thanks a
lot Tony